yo what's up guys this is prestige here
again oh hello and this is the next
episode in the hair bun series so today
we're going to it is a little creeper
tuition but I've patched up today we are
going to finish the road going down here
so let's start off with that and we need
to lock you up immediately and yeah
we'll see we're probably maybe do some
renovations to the house on a different
sound out of it no no no that's fine
eleven percent thing you guys there I'm
just wondering should I want to get to
the Sanchez leave at the sancho just
goof grab I'm just going to have grabbed
all the way through I love some lag boop
boop boop up the phone they're gonna
make it maybe I'll make a doc I'm like a
doc doc would be cool up up and grab
looks good going even going all the way
to sand the poo so yeah so this video
arm I wanted to talk a little bit about
the possibility of me doing I really
don't like maybe a new survival series
or additions to this one since I
recently found a mod actually two mods
one called a tale Kingdom tale of
kingdoms and the other one called a tale
kingdoms any other one called divine RPG
which you guys have probably heard of I
haven't heard of them at all before but
it appeared that well they both look
really awesome that kind of just like X
they add RPG isn't divine RPG obviously
and tail Tay
of kingdoms ads where's the water going
against me oh wow the entire water I'm
gonna have to fix that oh good a bucket
sorry but they add that and like divine
RPG adds a lot more stuff even then um
adds a lot more stuff than tale Kingdom
of tales even kingdoms tails still dad
like a ton of stuff so that we're
getting some lag hmm not that frames in
sec for me so far let's go normal um I
should make it a bit better but yeah so
I was thinking about yeah that's good um
was some freaky music that smooths in
all of that out and that smooth all that
up okay we're good so both of those look
really cool won't fail both of those
look really cool to me especially divine
RPG since that added like hundreds of
mobs and blocks and stuff which I'm like
that this looks amazing and it's awesome
and it looks like tons of fun I also
realized that those are the two MA two
of the biggest knowledge CaptainSparklez
is using for his ma's survival so that's
the thing but yeah I just wanted to see
if you guys would like me have to do
something of this I want to see if you
guys would like me to add that in if you
guys want me just to try implementing
since I think I once they updates a
divine RPG to work with 1.5 that I can
just add that entail kingdoms I'm not
sure if I can just throw in since I'm
quite a ways away from the spawn but ah
that's that and yeah
so this kind of wondering what you guys
think introduced and out I really want
to do for your guys's enjoyment so tell
me what you want and I would be happy to
do it since I definitely want to do
something like I could also instead of
just uh I didn't don't have to implement
it into this I could also make a new
survival of that stuff like in making
new survival series and yeah if you guys
will wrong me too I don't think 14 is
going to be enough let's just do that
poo poo poo I'm just making some fences
to go along with the docks boop boop ba
fail oppo 36 should be nothing and yeah
so tell me in the comments below tell me
what you guys wouldn't have me do and as
i said i'd be happy to do it and yes so
this yes i did please so i'm thinking of
doing like this Oh fell off I really
didn't need them any better we'll just
to make like a darkish feel fail fail
all my fail oh my fail three a bad
fences just cool well doc II
so tell ya tell me what you guys want me
to do since i think i will either start
a new also need to make the house figure
i'm going to either start a new survival
you guys when we do that and continue
this one or end this one or just add
divine RPG to this one because it adds
in tons of mobs and dimensions and all
that cool stuff and it looks like tons
of fun and I really want to have that so
yeah so let's make the house bigger hey
I torch blew off that ain't even notice
so the idol did I did say there was a
creeper explosion oh did it do debatin
how I should make the house bigger I
could expand this way
I can make like a building like and the
mind right there I can make a building
like coming out this way like another
full structure you say I just catch this
up I could fit into the structure in
here like I just push this back a bit I
go that and then build the other wooden
structure like honey or cobblestone it
could be in kind of Kabul what to do
must I get a stuck in like what uh what
I should do to create i think im gonna
make i want to come on i do build
something cobblestone me so I fail let's
move you like that like that cobblestone
Costa coastal mix chill and then kind of
ranch it out like that boo boo boo
so I can make in a doorway to it right
there just single doorway club doors
can't can't can't complex that music is
kind of loud and it's on seven percent
that isn't really do much one person two
percent let's make it that far yeah
that's good and all the way I do realize
that being like on the edge of the
mountain here like his stuff can fall
down on top so should probably
eventually light that up let's connect
this see I'm just going to break down
this wall eventually once I turn this
into a solid house maybe I can throw be
there and I want room I'm going to break
you down tree you are in the way be gone
with you
and yeah that should disappear soon
enough and yeah look at why choose the
sword as the ideal weapon to break that
let's leave that for class let's make oh
I could do Moss tongue I think I might
be like stone brick pillars you got to
be cool call this one wall pillars I
don't know experiment my whole hmm
maybe I could do like a pro I swear
doubt me I was thinking I could do like
some sorta like supporting arch oh let's
just get this built I like having lots
of class but do you like that
OOP OOP that's good boop boop I know
it's not that protective but it's good
and another one of you here I really
don't care for it right there so don't
make that something different just for
the outside of it oh fail try to place a
block right there now fail Hey oh my
gosh boy boy always not something I
would say put a boot do you see I like
building and this house definitely needs
some changes so build is good
I guess I could put like this here just
look good that
that'd be cool you got to be cool let me
make this it
looks good just that I had to do that
looks pretty good except for this like
that
feel like you just make it a double
doorway also I kind of want to make it
raised and we'll see sleep for Nick
sleep for the night time machine that's
a time we can work hmm how long ago and
recording okay kinda want to raise like
the entire building well let's try
something that might appease my wanting
to raise of the building okay twelve
stairs 16 stairs should be enough hey
bum bum bum bum bum bum no you see
that's that's why I want my sword I need
a sword with knock back there we go I'm
just going to kill the spider for his
experience give me your ox berrinche
thank you thank you very much come again
yeah I feel like and I'm breaking glass
but like I feel like it should be
another layer of cobblestone and like
that that would mean that would be like
that the hassle out there just to make
things different a little bit boom well
boom would that be good hang out look
cool Oh creep are you gonna get wrecked
so good I don't bow on me dang it Oh
hand me my bow I don't have a bow I
should really get meebo I thought I had
a bow yeah don't know what the building
is going to be
maybe I could expand this over since
this is annoying me and make it one more
glass think that look chill answer and I
could just make it ya think we do that
alright so luckily the only things I to
change is this I'm not to make it a
layer but it's like to change so I'm
going to want to fill all of this I
guess it only makes sense it be Kabul CS
will be elevated do 22 22 22 22 32 the
video is getting near the end but no I
want to make this like fortified
think i'll make the roof with like at
least one set of stairs on it wonder
let's build the next layer I don't think
I'm gonna have enough Kabul boom boom
wait oh I don't think it'll work but
yeah I think it's going to block it Oh
perfection enough pooh pooh pooh pooh
pooh pooh yeah I 10 more 10 cut it no it
will not are too short make that one
short not actually will that's cool
that's cool yeah I like that it looks
can I just want to finish this building
before I finish the episode so we're
going to be doing that in work Kabul um
die much stairs I've seven I don't know
how I want to make this so we need to
finish you over here I might need to get
rid of this trio fail and my axe outs
there's an acts like an axe yes no more
wood and i'm also going to break you
there's one more piece that you go
that's probably pick it up and just jump
to it from here now i don't want to do
this
I could like do it like that kind of
just experimenting as I go I kind of
want to do upside down stairs like that
work I'll fail he'll place on the upper
half of the block
good that work
let me so is here that means they need
to make the dirt longer here ok this is
well gonna take me longer than the video
so I'll just end the video here all
right oh no I'm into that oh I hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did if
you got all the way to the end I think
up no my W key is going crazy ok I'll in
the door I hope you guys a stop at WK
Joe Burke a top I think grid I hope
y'all enjoyed you got this far leave a
like comment favorite subscribe any of
those is muchly appreciated I feel like
it deserves one of them if you made all
the way to end so my name is prestige
and I like video games bye